Japan's economy is in danger.
And in order to maintain its massive size, Japan needs to put in the hours.
Japan lost its spot as the world's second-largest economy to China in 2011,...
...a title that it had previously held for 42 years.
Japan is dealing with a labor crisis.
Its population is aging fast and its birth rate is in decline.
That means its total population is going down.
And in the next 50 years, it's projected to shrink by nearly a third.
The population is expected to go from 127 million in 2015, to just 88 million by 2065.
There's two likely ways that a nation can compensate for the labor shortage,...
...immigrants or robots.
Japan has always been less inclined to accept immigrants.
In fact, its percentage of foreign workers is tiny...
...compared to other nations of large economies.
So without more immigrants, it's looking to robotics to fill in the gap.